à la veille de la manifestation demain à
paris des infirmières et de tout le
personnel soignant une équipe de soir 3
est allé voir comment anne hôpital
parisien fonctionne au quotidien avec
une grève qui touche la majorité du
personnel soignant émirats foule dit
nevers non-grévistes pas du tout maria
est infirmière en grève depuis le début
du mouvement
mais comme les 95 personnes de ses
services de chirurgie cardiaque à 100%
grévistes elle est réquisitionné assure
le travail en roulement avec les autres
ici malgré la lourdeur et la difficulté
des malades
l'atmosphère est bonne enfant et la
communication constante sur les enjeux
de la grève reprendrait très bien ce
qu'elles demandent
elles demandent des choses les plus
essentiels avoir du personnel pouvoir se
consacrer vraiment à 100 malades elles
le font mais pour le voit toujours
courir toujours toujours courir d'un
côté d'un autre quand même anormal de
travail qu'elles font demande beaucoup
beaucoup de dévouement est le deuil elle
le donne mais avec un salaire bon dur
soigner si on s'y tenir la main d'un
malade du terme on écoute et on c'est
vrai vous avez une maladie cra mais on
est là on peut en discuter et pas faire
un pansement la cinq minutes parce qu'on
a encore derrière dit pansement qui
attend si on demande qu'il y ait une
augmentation de personnel c'est parce
que justement chaque année ce n'est pas
sa place nous on est amené à faire le
travail de l'ex-magnat de l'ex soignante
fait de le travail de l'agent spitalier
et il ya tout un décalage détachées
surveillante chef du service
arlette choraux 31 ans d'ancienneté onze
mille francs par mois
je suis très vite
nous allons continuer la lutte et il
faut lutter au même moment assemblées
générales ont reprécise la plateforme
des revendications et surtout on
s'organise pour demain jour j avec
depuis le début du mouvement la même
préoccupation pour tous ne pas léser la
bonne marche de l'hôpital
deux impératifs le premier c'est assurer
la continuité des soins et bien entendu
les soins urgents
le second s'est gardée l'écoutent
vis-à-vis du personnel parce que c'est
un mouvement qui est profond et il faut
qu'une relation proche du personnel du
directeur à l'aide soignante personne
n'imaginait une grève d'une telle
ampleur à bruce et aujourd'hui encore la
grève on consultait gratis demain ce
sera le point culminant du mouvement
dans la rue et les différentes
coordinations attendent toujours des
pouvoirs publics des propositions qui
prennent en compte et leur statut et
leurs revendications salariales